[Música]
pausa en los ataques militares entre la
fuerza pública de Colombia y la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional tanto el presidente Gustavo
Petro como el comando central del grupo
ilegal ordenaron frenar la ofensiva
desde el 6 de julio y previo al 3 de
agosto cuando comenzará el cc bilateral
al fuego
preocupación en la comunidad
internacional por la crisis de seguridad
en Haití los estados miembros del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
defendieron este jueves el despliegue de
una fuerza multinacional en el país
Mientras que el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken dijo que
Washington trabaja para conformar una
fuerza internacional
Twitter amenaza con demandar a meta por
su nueva red social freds Un día después
del lanzamiento la aplicación del Pájaro
Azul acusa al gigante de las redes
sociales de quedarse con los servicios
de sus antiguos empleados para crear una
copia de su aplicación
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de Franz 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias de
América soy Santiago aristie comenzamos
esta emisión en Colombia a partir de
este jueves las fuerzas militares del
país y la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación Nacional pausan los ataques
mutuos tanto El Comando central del
grupo armado ilegal como el gobierno de
Gustavo petrom impartieron la orden a
sus respectivas tropas de frenar las
acciones militares ofensivas con miras
al 3 de agosto en esa fecha comenzará el
cc bilateral al fuego que pactaron en la
mesa de negociaciones y que va más allá
de una tregua en los ataques la pausa
inicial llega un día después de que el
eln secuestrara una Sargento y a sus dos
hijos menores de edad el informe es de
Juan pupiales
[Música]
promesas de paz el gobierno del
presidente Gustavo Petro comienza desde
este jueves un cese de hostilidades
junto con la guerrilla del eln con la
cual ya ha celebrado tres rondas de
conversaciones en un proceso de paz que
dio inicio a finales del año pasado Sin
embargo varias acciones violentas del
eln han marcado estas negociaciones la
última de ellas conocida es este
miércoles con el secuestro de una
Sargento y sus dos hijos de seis y ocho
años uno de ellos En condición de
autismo en el departamento de arauca
fronterizo con Venezuela Espero que el
eln no solo reconozca El secuestro sino
que haga las acciones inmediatas para
liberar a esta señora y a sus hijos y
tratemos de conectarnos con un país que
está diciendo por favor ya no más locura
de guerra lo que queremos es Paz pese al
secuestro el presidente mantiene su plan
original acordado en junio en la Habana
con el eln este 6 de Julio comienza el
cese de hostilidades Y a partir del 3 de
agosto entraría en vigor un alto el
fuego con los protocolos necesarios y
los mecanismos de verificación pero para
algunos expertos la pregunta gira en
torno a la voluntad de paz del eln son
lunares que no favorecen para nada el
inicio del César fuego entre el eln y
las fuerzas militares también pues parte
de el inicio de este css pues sería bien
acompañado en este caso de la liberación
de la Sarmiento y sus dos hijos y
también pues la suspensión de acciones
militares por parte de esta estructura
Armada ilegal desde la oposición del
centro democrático calificaron de farsa
este proceso con el eln se estima que
esta guerrilla cuenta con unos 4.000
efectivos y poner fin a la lucha armada
con ellos hace parte de la promesa de la
paz total bandera del presidente Petro
y los Estados miembros del Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU defendieron este
jueves el despliegue de una fuerza
multinacional en Haití la crisis
humanitaria y de seguridad de la nación
caribeña genera preocupación en la
comunidad internacional el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
dijo que su país trabaja de forma muy
activa para conformar una fuerza
internacional para ayudar a Haití además
aseguró que buscan construir una Policía
Nacional haitiana y que mantienen
conversaciones con países de la región
como escucharon de los líderes en Haití
como escucharon del pueblo haitiano como
escucharon del secretario general de las
Naciones Unidas como escucharon de la
oea
hay un consenso para que algún tipo de
fuerza multinacional apoye el trabajo de
la policía para tratar de crear algún
espacio y un clima más seguro para que
el trabajo que estamos haciendo con la
policía y los servicios de seguridad en
Haití tenga tiempo de afianzarse el
gobierno pueda recuperar el control del
país y no tenerlo dominado como lo está
en algunas partes por las pandillas
y desde hace casi dos meses Estados
Unidos dejó de aplicar el denominado
título 42 para deportar casi de manera
inmediata los migrantes que intentaban
cruzar sus fronteras de manera irregular
la norma creada en pandemia dejó de
estar en vigor el 11 de marzo y desde
entonces el número de extranjeros en los
límites con México bajó
considerablemente pero del otro lado
dejó consecuencias como un sistema más
engorroso para solicitar asilo
hace cerca de dos meses Finalizó el
polémico título 42 y desde entonces se
temía una afluencia masiva de migrantes
intentando cruzar la frontera entre
Estados Unidos y México Pero ha ocurrido
todo lo contrario
Así que lo que hemos visto desde el
final del título 42 es una disminución
en nuestras aprensiones para el mes de
junio en este momento estamos
promediando más de 430 apresiones por
día eso es en el sector de El Paso
comparándolo con el más alto que hemos
visto este año fiscal que fue el año
pasado de 2700 por día al título 42
siguieron nuevas normas implementadas
por el presidente Joe biden para
reprimir los cruces irregulares los
migrantes deben ahora pedir asilo desde
otro país vía una aplicación móvil o
haber visto su demanda de asilo
rechazada en un país por el que hayan
transitado y a los que se sorprenda
cruzando de forma irregular se le
impondrá un para entrar al país por al
menos cinco años es por eso que si antes
muchos intentaban pasar la frontera en
más de una oportunidad las más recientes
políticas migratorias los obligan ahora
a esperar en México por un proceso que
puede tomar meses o años bueno todos los
días igual porque uno se va al parque
allá vende porque sale a Pedida y BS y
veces no pide y así A veces como bien
dice además para muchos el uso de la
aplicación es difícil no tienen
teléfonos adecuados o un buen acceso a
internet
empujar a los migrantes detenerlos
abandonarlos o hacer deliberadamente el
proceso tan difícil que abandonen su
búsqueda para llegar a Estados Unidos es
una política cruel que solo pone en
riesgo a las personas Aunque Joe Byron
había prometido un sistema migratorio
más humano que el de su predecesor a día
de hoy no lo ha logrado
y hay polémica entre los gigantes de las
redes sociales Twitter de elon musk
amenaza con demandar a meta tras el
lanzamiento de streets su nueva
aplicación que le compite a la red del
Pájaro Azul así lo informó inicialmente
el sitio web de noticias semáforo
citando una carta enviada al ceo de la
casa matriz de Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
por parte del abogado de mosc El letrado
acusa a meta de contratar a ex empleados
de Twitter que tenían y continúan
teniendo acceso a los secretos
comerciales de la red social y otra
información altamente confidencial desde
que fue conocida la nueva app es
polémica por lo mucho que se parece a su
competencia
elon musky Mark Zuckerberg ya eran
vistos como archirrivales pero traeds el
último lanzamiento de meta que desafía
Twitter lleva la Batalla de los
multimillonarios a otro nivel los fans
de uno y otro se burlaron mutuamente con
fotos y videos y señalando los similares
que son las dos aplicaciones streets
podría crecer rápido ya que 2000
millones de personas usan Instagram ocho
veces más que Twitter
es difícil saber si el disgusto y el
descontento son lo suficientemente
fuertes como para provocar un Éxodo
masivo o si será algo así como una lenta
erosión de Twitter por meta Y si la
gente irá allí y se quedará muchos
usuarios están decepcionados por los
recientes acontecimientos en Twitter la
plataforma empuja ahora a los usuarios a
pagar por verificaciones y limita el
número de tuits que pueden leer la
plataforma también se ha enfrentado a
fallos técnicos
el fin de semana vimos como Twitter se
caía y se han puesto límites a los
usuarios para que no se vuelvan a romper
los servidores Así que si eres un
usuario normal solo podrás ver unos 5
minutos de tu ex al día no será hasta
dentro de unos meses que veremos Si la
gente decide quedarse en Twitter O se va
atreves
y en otras noticias la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de Estados
Unidos aprobó por primera vez el uso de
un medicamento que ralentiza los
síntomas del Alzheimer el fármaco
lecanemaba mostró ser eficaz a la hora
de retrasar los efectos de esta
enfermedad neurodegenerativa la fda se
había otorgado al medicamento una
aprobación acelerada el pasado enero
pero todavía quedaba por realizar un
último ensayo clínico que ha dado
resultados satisfactorios
y llegamos así al final de esta emisión
informativa ustedes pueden ampliar estas
noticias y conocer muchas más en Franz
24.com siguen junto a nosotros
[Música]